From Britney Spears to Harry Potter,
he is one of the all time heroes, right?
But now Daniel Radcliffe is playing a villain
opposite Sandra Bullock in "The Lost City",
and on a press tour, he got hit with a huge question.
He says, "They asked who are
your three biggest celebrity crushes", right?
And "People" reports that while he's in a very happy
10 year relationship ship with actress Erin Drake,
he was willing to name names.
So we have them right here.
His top three celebrity crushes are
Juno Temple, Cameron Diaz and Drew Barrymore.
Yes, Harry Potter's hot to trot for you girl.
That is crazy.
It seems like he has a type,
but I was Googling him and his girlfriend,
and they're just so lovely.
This is so fun, I mean, it's so fun to name...
I don't, who would you pick Rossy?
For celebrity crushes?
Oh, I'm glad you asked.
Okay, let's start.
Currently I'm really into Andrew Garfield, right?
From "tick, tick...BOOM!", "The Eyes of Tammy Faye."
You know what, you called him a walking jaw line,
and I can't get it out of my head now.
Yeah, he's jawline goals for sure.
And then old school crush for me was AC Slater, Mario Lopez,
thank you very much.
And do you know who my first celebrity crush ever was?
Are you ready?
Who?
Aladdin, thank you very much.
I remember...
(audience cheering)
I was on a date.
I was in eighth grade, seventh grade,
I was on a date with Amy Taylor, you know who you are.
And she tried to kiss me and I was like, "Amy, do you mind?
I'm watching Aladdin."
That really open vest on that carpet.
That's a true story.
One of my first crushes was Darth Vader.
I think, I know, I know, I know,
you're all gonna be like what?
You're so twisted.
I used to have this reoccurring dream about him
when I was a kid, and it had definite sexual undertones.
That is so weird.
I think we all can agree, sometimes a mask is hot.
And maybe I had daddy issues, I don't know.
Diagnose yourself.
As I grew up, I definitely gravitated
always towards funny madness.
You know, like David Letterman, of course.
You know, and funny enough, because I like funny men,
I got interested and I was like,
you know what would be so great, is a dating app
for people who like humor.
Well, it turns out the "Boston Business Journal" reports
"Smile" is a dating app that matches people
by sense of humor.
Really?
Yes.
(audience cheering)
It's developed by Melissa Mullen and it launches April 15th.
Now here's how it works.
Instead of swipe on profile pics,
users will rate funny content from TikTok and Instagram,
and then an algorithm will match your sense of humor
to people who laugh at the same things that you find funny.
It's like funny bone to funny bone.
And the app also plans to blur profile pics at first,
so that you don't get a full view of someone
until you've been chatting for a bit,
like it's humor overlooked.
I mean, what do you think?
I'm really into this.
Jaw lines will sag, right?
But LOL's are here forever.
And I think in your relationship you have to find
the same kind of stuff funny, or it's just not gonna work.
You know, there are days where Wellington and I
will just text each other back and forth
with just memes, no words.
On Tuesday, he sent me a meme of a guy in a mankini
holding tacos, dancing like this.
And I knew that meant we were going
to Mexican food that night, say no more.
That's all I need.
That is couple goals.
Thank You.
It's true.
I have to say, I'm really looking forward
to this dating app.
Thank you for putting it out there in the world.
And I can't wait to see how it works.
Are you gonna join it?
Maybe.
Oooh.
Maybe someone else out there
likes Darth Vader and giggles.
(upbeat music)